le défi était de taille pour les
escrimeurs trappistes en quarts de
finale du championnat de france par
équipe de fleuret samedi dernier face à
hull élite de l'escrimé française et
mondiale
vincent simon vainqueur du circuit
national victor sintès membre de
l'équipe de france olympique et surtout
bioshock troisième des jeux olympiques
de londres pour trappe le bondissant
benoît journée le premier en piste
mon héros de français lance idéalement
les saint quentinois cinq touches à 4
c'est alors que se présente lors du
second relais
le champion de france junior 2012 cédric
npd fort d'une allonge impressionnante
l'espoir trappistes fait un festival en
contre et permet à trappes de mener 10
touches à 7
il va même réussir l'exploit de tenir
tête aux médaillés olympiques shea dans
le quatrième relais 19 partout les deux
équipes se tiennent tant de touche
jusqu'à 30 29
c'est le moment choisi par why et
vincent simon pour infliger un 5-1 aux
jeunes et aînés et le sud coréen chol
termine parfaitement au travail
score final 45-30 rap s'arrête pour la
deuxième année consécutive en quarts de
finale
la plupart des tiers qui était en face
effectivement on d entraînement régulier
voire quotidiens de notre côté c'est pas
c'est pas forcément le cas on est pas on
s'entraîne pas autant donc forcément
physiquement au moment ça a été un peu
plus dur de votre côté et ils ont fait
la différence je pense aujourd'hui
physiquement parce que jusqu'à 30 chacun
chacun a tenu son rôle et
et puis voilà forcément c'était plus un
peu plus dur